in the mountains above longer being the
world's northernmost town the glaciers
are retreating rapidly even on small
bird just 800 miles from the North Pole
many can only be reached with a hike to
higher altitude
Andy Hudson has been studying the Fox
pond a glass here for more than a decade
watching the ice melt by two meters
every summer there's a gentle gradual
sort of death scenario if you like for
the glass ears
the Arctic is heating up twice as fast
as anywhere else on the planet walking
on the ice is perilous for the unwary
hidden below the surface are tunnels
carved out by meltwater cascading down
the mountainside where the thin roof
falls in there's a portal to the
glaciers fragile interior the rapidly
changing climate is bringing new risks
to people who live on the island but
this is obviously all collapsed in and
people need to be aware of this and
sometimes when you're walking in these
rivers in front of the glass here you
suddenly see this sort of ice roof
blocks of ice just flowing out very
suddenly people in Longyearbyen are used
to living in a harsh climate but now
they face new hazards snow barriers have
been installed above the town changing
snow patterns have caused major
avalanches and two people have died the
normal is the new normal so it's normal
it's raining in midwinter it's normal
that we have heavy precipitation it's
normal that we have more avalanche
activities the Town Council has now
evacuated those vulnerable to further
avalanches their house is condemned so
how many people lived here I think is it
140 140 long here and we've all had to
find new places to live
Longyearbyen x' priest says the new
threat has changed the town there is
this kind of new insecurity one thing
has been hit by an avalanche when you're
outside you know you you know that's the
kind of risk when you're in your house
you're supposed to be safe so that's a
major change in its kind of all also
psychologically global warming is also
affecting the most Arctic of pastimes
traditional dog sleds are increasingly
being replaced by buggies at the snow
season gets shorter lifestyles are
having to change in the new climate
Thomas More Sky News small bird